je vous explique mais avant sa part on
tue pas
regardez les images à l'écran
maintenant je vous dis que les trois
objets encadré rouge sont têtus fa
est ce que vous pourriez lister les
autres tu fasses de limoges
je vais assigner à chaque image une
latrine numéro pouvez-vous dresser la
liste des images qui sont des tu vas je
vous invite à remplir le sondage en
descriptif et en commentaire et anglais
pour donner votre avis histoire qu'on
puisse comparer les capacités de
généralisation des chacun d'entre nous
allez faites le sait pour la science
et
l
cette expérience a été
c'est par la chercheuse lorraine schmitt
alors doctorante ou et mighty et de
façon remarquable ce que lorraine
schmitt a découvert c'est qu'il se
trouve que nous sommes tous globalement
d'accord sur la signification du mot du
phare et ça à bien y réfléchir c'est
vraiment remarquable
mais aussi perturbant on eu que trois
exemples de tuf à et on a eu aucun
exemple de ce que n'est pas un tu fais
et pourtant rien qu'à partir de cela on
est capable de généraliser de manière
relativement similaire mais cette
généralisation est elle du coup abusive
et abusives ou non comment l'expliquer
quel mécanisme nous permet d'effectuer à
peu près la même généralisation
voilà une question fondamentale en
psychologie puisque l'apprentissage de
la langue par les enfants est d'ailleurs
par les adultes souvent aussi cet
apprentissage s'appuie beaucoup sur la
généralisation à partir de très peu de
données est souvent uniquement à partir
de donner des exemples positifs par
exemple un enfant peut apprendre de
fascinant ce qu'est un poisson à partir
de très peu d'exemples d'image de
poisson mais à quelles règles au pays
alors cet apprentissage tout l'enfant
qu'elle l'algorithme exécute le cerveau
des enfants et comment un gamin ou une
gamine revient-il août elle a affirmé
que les baleines sont des poissons
pour comprendre ce qui se passe dans la
tête d'un enfant qui voit une baleine ou
dans la tête de l'un d'entre vous quand
vous voyez un tu vas dans un article de
2011 trois chercheurs du hem haïti avec
notamment le génialissime georges tin
bornes ces trois chercheurs ont proposé
une explication bayésienne relativement
simple de ce que george kennan ban
appelle parfois le scandale de
l'induction l'idée des trois auteurs
c'est que l'ensemble des choses peut
naturellement être structurée sous la
forme d'un arbre dans le jargon on parle
de modèles bayésiens hiérarchique qui a
d'ailleurs à voir avec les graphiques
aux autres dont on a parlé dans
l'épisode 22 les auteurs présentent en
particulier une manière bayésienne de
construire un arbre pour classer
différents objets et des algorithmes
pour y arriver en pratique et bon c'est
un peu compliqué donc je vais pas
détailler leurs méthodes je vais juste
dire que ça fait appel un concept assez
cool appelé le processus du restaurant
chinois c'est un vrai truc de machine
learning de façon cruciale les auteurs
montrent que à force de voir des animaux
ou des objets étranges nos cerveaux ont
affiné inconsciemment de tels arbres
bayésiens qui nous permettent de classer
les objets y compris quand on n'a pas de
mots pour identifier les catégories mais
alors sachant atteint l'arbre la
généralisation des tuffes à devient une
procédure simple et naturelle en gros et
en donner un arbre et des objets qui
correspondent à une catégorie il suffit
de placer ces trois objets dans l'arbre
et de remonter l'arbre jusqu'à trouver
le noeud le plus bas qui leur couple
tous la généralisation naturel perds tu
fasses correspond alors à tous les
objets qui descendent de ce plu pas ne
commun et si cette procédure peut vous
rappeler des méthodes de biologie c'est
bien le cas et on y viendra nul besoin
toutefois d'invoquer la théorie de
l'évolution pour la justifier en effet
cette construction d'une classe d'objets
à partir de quelques exemples positifs
seulement c'est une approche qui se
justifie en fait pleinement avec un
simple argument bayésiens en effet la
classe défini par le plus bas ne commun
n'est autre que la classe de descendance
qui maximise la vraisemblance des
données en effet si on prend un peu plus
bas alors il y aura une donnée à savoir
dans ce cas l'exemple de ce tu vas qui
invalide l'hypothèse se ne définit la
classe des tuffes à ne s'agirait donc
pas d'un noeud cohérents avec les
données mais inverse si on prend un
noeud plus haut alors chaque donnée
devient moins probable car il ya
davantage de données qui aurait pu être
identifiés comme des tuffes à
l'hypothèse lenovo définit la classe des
tuffes à colleret alors beaucoup moins
avec les données que l'hypothèse le plus
bas de commun défini la classe des
tuffes art sa chance cet arbre pour
structurer les objets il ya alors
quelque chose de profondément
rationnelle ou disons moins bayésiens
dans le scandale de l'induction alors il
y aurait des subtilités à ajouter à cela
comme le fait d'invoquer un a priori sur
ce que sont les tu vas notamment
lorsqu'on en parle pour une raison
spécifique
le fait d'avoir un raisonnement plus
probabiliste qui conclurait davantage en
le plus bas ne commun défini
probablement la classe des plus forts ou
le fait que l'enseignant peut vouloir
identifier les tu vas dans toute leur
diversité
pour augmenter la crds et dans son
hypothèse le plus bas de commun défini
probablement la place des tuffes art et
comme cette vidéo va déjà être assez
longue je vais vous laisser méditer tout
cela tout seul car j'ai surtout envie de
revenir aux baleines
de façon remarquable tout ce réseau
construit par les chercheurs en
neurosciences et en machine learning que
l'on en fait parfaitement avec la
phylogénie c'est à dire la branche de la
biologie qui étudient l'arbre du vivant
en fait de nos jours la construction
même de cet arbre est souvent automatisé
par des algorithmes qui s'appuie
justement sur des modèles bayésiens
hiérarchique de surcroît en phylogénie
la construction de l'arbre du vivant
répond à la quête de l'histoire du
vivant en effet les biologistes cherche
à faire en sorte que les noeuds qui lie
les espèces animales correspondent à
l'existence d'un ancêtre commun par
exemple pour identifier les mammifères
techniquement les biologistes vont
d'abord construire l'arbre du vivant à
partir des ressemblances morphologiques
comme la structure osseuse ou la
capacité d'al été ensuite les
biologistes pour identifier le plus bas
ne commun à tous les animaux qu'ils
considèrent être des mammifères tous les
descendants de cet ancêtre commun sont
alors qualifiés de mammifères cette
approche moderne a amené les biologistes
a souvent chambouler leur représentation
du vivant il ya par exemple considérer
que les baleines sont en fait est
davantage proche les humains qu'elles ne
le sont des requins voilà qui fait dire
par foire est certain que les baleines
ne sont pas des poissons comme les
autres ceux qui montent dans une
approche humano centric semble
justifiable voir que les baleines ne
sont pas des poissons tout court et là
le problème avec cette phrase c'est ce
qu'il se passe lorsqu'on essaie de
définir les poissons pour cela appeler
vous nous faut prendre tous les exemples
de poissons à notre disposition et
identifier le plus bas ne commun à tous
ces poissons et là patatras ce plus
récent s'être commun est aussi un
ancêtre des humains et des baleines
selon la définition phylogénétique on en
vient à la conclusion qui est le titre
de cette vidéo à savoir le fait que les
baleines sont des poissons comme j'ai un
côté un peu taquin j'ai eu envie de
rajouter des poissons comme les autres
on
alors malgré tout cela je suis sûr que
beaucoup d'entre vous ont encore envie
de rétorquer que même si les baleines
sont des poissons elles n'en restent pas
moins des poissons pas comme les autres
notamment car elle respire de l'air sont
vieillis par et à l'être même leurs
petits étrangement ce débat de
sémantique a pris une dimension légale à
new york en 1818 quand un commerçant
d'huile de baleines prétendit que la loi
sur l'huile de poisson ne s'appliquait
pas à ces produits au tribunal le
médecin et l'historien naturel docteur
samuel mitchell dit alors la chose
suivante en tant qu homme de science je
peux affirmer qu'une baleine n'est pas
plus un poisson qu'un homme laid
personne ne prétend le contraire
aujourd'hui à part des avocats et des
politiciens
je ne sais pas comment comprendre cette
phrase techniquement phylogénétiquement
j'ai envie de dire que c'est juste dans
ce cas c'est très trompeur la baleine et
l'homme sont des poissons et il aura été
du coup tout aussi juste de dire qu'une
baleine est tout autant un poisson car
aucun ou qu'une carpe
je suis pas sûr que c'est ce qu'il
voulait dire quoi qu'il en soit le
docteur samuel michel n'aura pas
convaincu le juge et les jurés
légalement la baleine fut reconnue comme
un poisson et le commerçant a dû payer
une amende pour ne pas avoir payé la
taxe sur l'huile de poisson mais vous
pourriez me dire il semble quand même y
avoir un sens selon lequel les baleines
ne sont pas comme les autres poissons
après tout elles n'ont pas de branchini
décarie est en effet justement la
définition wikipédia des poissons les
décrit comme des animaux vertébrés
aquatiques à branchies pourvu de
nageoires dont le corps est généralement
couvert d'écaillés selon cette
définition qui pour le coup n'est
absolument pas phylogénétique les
baleines ne sont en effet pas des
poissons mais cette définition n'étant
pas cohérente avec l'arbre du vivant
étrangement elle pousse des biologistes
a considéré qu'elle n'est pas
scientifiquement valide et que selon la
science ils seraient plus de considérer
que les poissons n'existe pas il ya même
des livres qui le prétendre et ça à bien
y réfléchir
c'est une expression extrêmement bizarre
la prochaine fois qu'on me demande de
restaurants si je mange du poisson dois
je vraiment rétorqué désolé je ne peux
pas manger ce qui n'existe pas
en fait ce qu'il faut
les poissons et profondément en modèle
dépendantes dans le modèle
phylogénétique du vivant les poissons un
pull erokhin les baleines et les humains
dans la définition wikipédia sq les
baleines les humains ne sont pas des
poissons et ça c'est parce que l'un des
fils de wikipédia n'est pas
phylogénétique lé phénotypiques c'est à
dire que la classification du vivant
selon cette définition de wikipédia
correspond aux attributs physiologiques
des animaux mais j'aimerais insister
dessus la définition phénotypiques de
wikipédia ne correspond pas à la
définition phénotypiques intuitive de
ceux qui observent les animaux de loin
cette définition intuitive qui est celle
des enfants est sans doute celle du
grand public des années 1800 c'est sans
doute davantage une définition comme un
poisson est un animal marin avec des
nageoires et en ce sens intuitif les
baleines sont des poissons c'est
d'ailleurs le mot cétacés qui regroupe
les baleines et les dauphins entre
autres ça signifie littéralement grands
poissons
clairement il y à un modèle du vivant
utilisés par nos ancêtres dans lequel
les baleines sont des poissons ou du
moins on semble pouvoir dire
étymologiquement que les baleines sont
des poissons mais il ya mieux et même
beaucoup mieux pour comprendre la modèle
dépendance de la classification du
vivant dans un article remarquable de
2008 charles kemp est toutefois
tennebaum encore lui ont conçu un modèle
le bayeusain hiérarchique capable de
structurer le vivant non seulement sur
la forme d'un arbre de descendance mais
aussi sous la forme de graphe de
similarités un peu comme ce qu'on reçoit
ont circulé sur twitter est ce que leurs
expériences ont montré c'est que bon
d'un côté la formule de belgique
redoutablement efficaces pour identifier
les meilleurs modèles pour décrire
d'étonner c'est une forme de méthane
apprentissage incroyablement puissante
mais surtout deuxièmement la
classification du vivant évoluent au fur
et à mesure qu'on considère davantage de
caractéristiques du vivant en étudiant
que cinq aspects du vivant les modèles
bayésiens hankenne a regroupé les
baleines avec les dauphins et les
phoques mais aussi avec les truites et
les saumons et même avec les pingouins
les alligators et les icônes mais de
façon intéressante en considérant
davantage de caractéristiques les
modèles bayésiens en viennent à
regrouper les baleines plus
spécifiquement avec les dauphins et les
phoques et
si avec ses parents et avec davantage de
caractéristiques encore s'approche d'une
classification plus proche de la
classification phylogénétique
normand et j'insiste bien dessus le
modèle du vivant ainsi obtenu n'aura
aucune raison de coïncider avec le
modèle phylogénétique vivant après tout
à cause de la convergence évolutive
évoqué dans cette vidéo de dirty
belgique il faut s'attendre à ce que de
nombreuses espèces historiquement très
différente soit néanmoins phénotypiques
mans très similaires n'aurait alors deux
modèles différents tous deux entraînés
avec extrêmement de données et qu'il
qualifierait le vivent de manière
différente et alors il pourrait
subsister des biologistes parmi nous qui
persiste à penser que le modèle
phylogénétique du vivant de moeurs alors
néanmoins plus vrai que le modèle final
typique sauf que bon à côté on peut
douter du fait que le concept même
d'arbres du vivant et vrai cet article
prétend au contraire que l'arbre du
vivant organise les données de manière
utile sans postuler une vérité
évolutionniste fondamentale mais surtout
comme le signale parfaitement cette
citation il ya sans doute davantage eux
de se demander si telle ou telle
classification du vivant est utile pour
synthétiser la structure et la variété
du vivant des modèles non phylogénétique
peuvent alors être d'une utilité
parfaitement complémentaires aux modèles
phylogénétique notamment quand il s'agit
par exemple de décrire les stratégies
développées par le vivant pour survivre
dans tel ou tel environnement bref vous
avez peut-être l'impression que je
pinaille avec les définitions et c'est
vrai que ces discussions de sémantique
ne paraissent beaucoup moins importante
que prend à partie de cette vidéo mais
j'étais un an - a souligné que si vous
êtes biologistes ou philosophes et
souhaité affirmer que les baleines ne
sont pas des poissons alors il vous
faudrait sans doute vivement questionner
d'autres affirmations de club les
oiseaux sont des dinosaures ou les
humains sont des singes plutôt que de
reprendre sèchement ce qui à partir de
définition phénotypiques conclu que les
oiseaux ne sont pas des dinosaures ou
que les humains ne sont pas des saints
anges il serait peut-être préférable de
reconnaître l'intérêt pratique du modèle
phénotypiques du vivant avant de
présenter aussi l'intérêt scientifique
du modèle phylogénétique quand bien même
ce modèle phylogénétique force à
reconnaître les baleines sont des
poissons comme les autres
pour finir cette vidéo j'aimerais si
c'était plus encore fera notion de
réalisme modèle dépendant que j'ai
découverte dans le livre de granby
zareen de stephen hawking eléonore de
mollo 10 nov alors malheureusement les
deux auteurs ont adopté un ton très
hautain et mal informés vis-à-vis de la
philosophie ce qui a conduit à une levée
de boucliers chez les philosophes
néanmoins l'idée philosophique de
rocking blood of me semble très
intéressante en tout cas elle a
bouleversé ma compréhension des sciences
mais surtout cette idée me semble être
une conséquence naturelle du bail à nice
mme en bref selon cette philosophie le
mot existence doit systématiquement être
rattaché un modèle considérer ainsi si
on veut être précis ne faudrait quand
même parlé de la force de gravité de
manière absolue l'existence de cette
force devra être subordonnée un modèle
dans lequel on raisonne vis-à-vis du
monde dès lors il y aurait des modèles
ou la force de gravité existent comme la
physique newtonienne et les modèles loi
n'existe pas comme la relativité
générale où le modèle son bar des
particules
de même il ya des modèles ou les
particules de lumière appelé photos
existent comme la mécanique quantique et
des modèles oui elle n'existe pas comme
l'électromagnétisme de maxwell voilà qui
pourrait clarifier ce que les
biologistes entendent par les poissons
n'existe pas pour être plus rigoureux ce
qu'il faudrait dire c'est que dans le
modèle phylogénétique du vivant n'existe
pas de clad c'est-à-dire deux groupes
définis par les descendants d'un ancêtre
commun n'existe donc pas de clad qui
regroupe la truite et la dip ne met pas
les baleines et les humains pour cette
raison le concept intuitive de poissons
et la définition wikipédia de poissons
n'existe pas dans le modèle pilot
génétique et en un sens il s'agit là
d'un futur du modèle phylogénétique et
pas d'un bug puisqu'il permet de
clarifier la structure phylogénétique du
vivant en empêchant l'introduction de
concepts boguey un peu comme certains
langages de programmation vous empêche
de construire certains objets parce que
vous risquez d'écrire des incohérences
et bien d'une certaine manière de la
même manière qu'on pourrait dire que les
poissons n'existe pas en théorie
quantique des champs ou dans le modèle
standard de la physique des particules
et qu'il ne s'agit non pas là d'un bug
mais d'une feature de ses modèles et
alors on pourrait continuer à penser
qu'il existe un vrai modèle du monde et
qu'une définition ou un concept peut
être considéré vrai s'il existe dans ce
vrai modèle du monde sauf que en
pratique quand bien même ce vrai modèle
existerait
construire est extrêmement difficile
voire impossible voire inutile car ce
modèle pourrait être alors trop complexe
à penser et à exploiter en pratique
notamment lorsque vous allez chez le
poissonnier il est sans doute préférable
exploiter un modèle utile du monde par
exemple un modèle du monde qui classe le
vivant par le goût de leur chair ou
peut-être de façon plus éthique par la
souffrance que l'animal en dur lorsqu'il
est pêché bref vous connaissez de point
de vue bayésiens sur toutes ces
questions tous les modèles sont faux
mais certains sont utiles